[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
dépendance et devant la foule est est
reportée à ce soir l'était aussi a raté
son entrée il fait gris sur la majeure
partie de france mais cela ne va pas
durer nous dit la météo le soleil doit
être au rendez vous dès demain
[Musique]
m
charlotte qui veut l'entendre
[Musique]
d'abord passer la nuit bref comme henry
qui revient aussi la peau quémander non
non
[Musique]
allez vous
si je joue et se plaît le plus aux
jambons
je sentis
jeudi
[Musique]
le chauffeur
cauchon une plaquette de rillettes
aebischer
ça va
[Musique]
il fallait
les voitures des yeux
[Musique]
paris à l'école je suis sage
avec ça ils vont avoir un bon point le
modulaire
marimbert
effet de la rendre invisible
[Musique]
chez madame si vous parlez
si je te tue
je veux manger une butée j'ai un moteur
rotatif ici
d'accord
car la rooney
or là
à l'honneur
kp
[Musique]
sylla
vt
[Musique]
première tournée venir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à tanger des 100 après
d'abord de faire habiller janvier a bien
commencé
[Musique]
les français
l emprunteur
huit cerveaux encore jeune en qui faire
beaucoup car il faudrait le foncier dont
tu te rends compte la voir une langue
ans
ainsi le monde avant que j'arrive assez
physique et non des ptt mois chez les
félins petit coup de patin de saillé
badakou 10 et en travaillant le slam en
travaillant moi j'écoute je vivais ma
courir sur l'hôpital d'aquila quantités
mais cette cargaison faisait car selon
lui les rades soro sont lourds et court
et court les rousses entreprises unes
dans les autres
chaque fois que tu fais là coup de patin
cas c'est mouillé comme ça c'est moyen
sur le panneau
ça tire alors sur le sort de ma chance
bah oui
[Musique]
qui sait qu'on ait augmenté de 1 hier
moi j'étais un grand nom pareil on
reprend le tpir iqu
j'ai bossé
[Musique]
j'ai jamais paru je suis payé le pixon
bon et combien je dois gérer toute cette
gabegie 135 et 135 euros pour un coût
charlot ces outils pour toi c'est la
victoire ainsi à 3 chez charlie c'est
l'aveu de reverser ces normes
[Musique]
les cinq rapports
madame
et
bon alors je suis à jour dans les
comptes
[Musique]
alors touché
il a tellement sélection aussi
[Musique]
pour la facturation des violonistes
tous
car lorsque yann 30
battus pour l'instar ment comme
d'habitude
whitera 60
bon
heymans pas pour moi le match
[Musique]
jacques
la reine pour l'agglo vous avez dû
connaître les seins de son appel et les
fleuristes qui réunit d'atomes aux
appels à ben laden
harry a rappelé que c'était moi ni la
plus qu'ils ont construit une école
lundi jusqu'à sabrina st remy même à
saint rémy vous savez sauveur sur la
gauche non pas pour les dossards et
j'avais sous la main
[Musique]
maintenant il a pdg des pavillons à
ouides en pierre et en pierre chaque
chantier
mes chers collègues
[Musique]
et bruxelles jeudi
à
hahaha
à l'aller
ah ah
[Rires]
là
à
[Musique]
là
paris fait les 2 me bram du whisky les
trois-quarts droit n'est pas mort
carrick
à paris
les cas sociaux doit être traité
autrement mais pas par l'interruption de
grossesse
mais alors qui prendra l'année c'est si
c'est la femme qui prend la décision et
dans tous les cas bien entendu elle
prendra la décision après avoir
nécessairement obligatoirement consulter
un médecin
elle consultera un autre médecin soit
médecins hospitaliers soit un
spécialiste et bien entendu aussi tout
c'est à la trame bien la décision il
faudra qu'elle de rennes cette décision
c'est une réflexion pas de plusieurs
jours mais en définitive c'est elle qui
prendra la décision et par conséquent
c'est à elle qu'incombe la
responsabilité nécessairement et non
seulement c'est un des médecins dans un
hôpital dans une clim
artiste qui aurait été coeur et est
agréé par la sécurité sociale pour
l'ensemble des charges
la deuxième chambre ajax à la juventus
la finale de l'est sont d'europe se sont
heureusement là depuis la fin du match
c'est à dire vers 23 heures s'il n'y a
pas de prolongation bonne soirée à tous
prenant déclic
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est mal vu
pourquoi +17 brit air qui vous parle
grand tirage
depuis le magnifique stade de l'étoile
rouge à belgrade dans une salle pour les
faire descendre je peux demander avec
roues et nicolet-yamaska du capitaine
d'alvalade votre stratégie
le joueur devrait denis olivennes depuis
malenfant wrangler salvador mourinho
était de lancer la bagarre
pas content c'est au départ grave erreur
ce dernier disait oui nous revient très
belle parade le dos
ah les cons
[Musique]
les actifs
c'est comme un test au point de penalty
à chaque coup les qualifiera pas droit
[Musique]
est-ce que j'ai joué la tordre 12,6 de
14,12 homme de terroir des braves
je n'ai pas regardé du tout à fait à
jour à la date de naissance c'est tout
il faut à berlin vers le bourg je n'ai
pas regardé ça regarde ils sont là pour
rien 35 35 ou alors on va falloir c'est
chez vous abbas et astronome de la
gamelle quoi j'ai une chanson assez
faible j'ai fait je marque de tourner
sadia tournée toi bien fait la première
parce que d'habitude je me 14,6 et un
but là-bas qu'il ya deux ans je le 14 de
ces entretiens il a fait me lors de ses
sept en 2000
sur les manques de poma maire ne l'a pas
joué de 14,6 même pas venus de
l'étranger
on va faire le coup du mystère une carte
ici
pinafore
11 may 14 14 ou 15 16
c'est beau c'est beau et généreux
excusez moi
bonsoir merci mon stylo j'ai une
histoire charlot qui seront revues
pornos
bon vraiment jusqu'à paris c'est toi
enfin qu'un père des bonbons chirac est
jugé bien ensemble je quittais barreaux
j'espère je t'avais en vacances quand
même j'irai dois m'en tombent mal qu'il
avoue dans le maquis des fois tu viens
ou where volé ces partis ont déjà d'un
plan fois de marche a indiqué ce
vendredi
[Musique]